bonsoir mercredi 26 mai bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de cette édition et
jusqu'au 30 mai c'est la semaine
européenne de la jeunesse un événement
qui a lieu tous les deux ans pour
permettre aux jeunes de débattre
contribuer à des initiatives et de
connaître les possibilités offertes par
l'uae dans ce journal reportage au lycée
blériot de trappes
pendant trois jours les élèves parlent
justement de l'europe et ils ont échangé
ce matin avec une eurodéputée
elle devrait relier à l'horizon 2030
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles la ligne
18 est sur les rails les travaux de
génie civil ont commencé et nouveautés
sur le tracé a émergé depuis quelques
mois une partie du viaduc du plateau de
saclay sera finalement mise au sol le
point sur le chantier a invité bertrand
au lion maire de magny les hameaux
et puis le monde de la culture prend peu
à peu ses droits hier le théâtre coluche
de plaisir accueilli en avant-première
vienne 1913 a été joué devant des
professionnels par la compagnie influent
scène avant une représentation à
destination du public et ce en octobre à
suivre également tout à l'heure
l'épisode 2 de notre dossier consacré
aux archives départementales des
yvelines le site partage également ses
trésors grâce à la numérisation
et je vous le disais dans les titres
c'est en ce moment la semaine européenne
de la jeunesse au lycée louis-blériot de
trappes des élèves ont participé
aujourd'hui à une visioconférence avec
la député européenne française irène
tôlerie un rendez vous qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre du programme erasmus mené
avec la structure yvelinoise michael et
demi d'euros a pu suivre les échanges
journée spéciale pour ces six élèves du
lycée louis-blériot de trappes ce
mercredi 26 mai ils ont pu discuter avec
une députée européenne dans le cadre
d'un programme erasmus débute en 2018
la femme politique française irène
tôlerie a pu partager son expérience
lors d'une séance de questions réponses
pendant une heure j'ai trouvé super
intéressant il ya beaucoup d'échangés
entre les élèves et et la députée
européenne pouvoir apprendre ce que plus
en profondeur ce qu'une personne dans un
poste de député européen puisse faire de
manière générale on peut on peut savoir
à peu près ce qu'ils font l'intégralité
de ce rendez-vous a été réalisée en
anglais pour pouvoir permettre à
plusieurs classes étrangères partenaires
de participer
l'événement s'est déroulé en simultané
dans des classes chypriote néerlandais
et slovaque
l'occasion également pour les trappistes
de travail et des langues étrangères
ça permet de travailler l'anglais oui
parce qu'on a une plateforme
virtuel où les élèves entre les visites
ont réalisé des activités et bien sûr
les échanges et en anglais ils ont
également appris quelques mots de langue
de nos partenaires des slovaques de
drake
ce type d'initiative n'est pas inédite
pour la structure des programmes
européens sont menées depuis une dizaine
d'années à trappes
on en voit régulièrement nos élèves en
stage et puis ce projet a permis à des
élèves de cp de terminale bac pro et 1re
bac pro de travailler en commun sur un
projet en relation avec la culture
d'autres animations sont programmées
jusqu'à ce vendredi dans la structure
avec notamment une visite virtuelle du
parlement européen
ce partenariat entre les lycées erasmus
va continuer à se développer se
poursuivra au minimum pendant encore
sept en une journée dans la peau de
diplômes à des nations unies c'est ce
qu'ont vécu douze étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin
hier mardi ils ont participé à
l'événement sky moon au programme
organisation de conférences et débats
elle les précisions dans ce sujet de
bérangère bourgoin la deuxième édition
de l'événement de simulation des nations
unies de sky moon a eu lieu mardi 25 mai
pour l'occasion 12 étudiants volontaires
de l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines sont devenus des diplomates le
temps d'une journée
chacun s'est vu attribuer un pays et ils
ont choisi une commission en anglais ou
en français
une association étudiante donc du coup
qui regroupe plusieurs étudiants de
l'antenne de sky mule donc de l'ensemble
de l'université et elle a pour but de
mettre la simulation des nations unies à
l'échelle étudiante et qui devront donc
du coup des étudiants qui devront
représenter des délégations pour des
sujets très spécifique qui signifie un
peu tous les pays du monde
le but de l'association sky moon
permettre aux étudiants de développer
leurs connaissances politiques et
diplomatiques
ils ont débattu et proposer des
solutions sur des problématiques
internationales
ça mettait en place de comités le
communiqué de l'unicef et le comité
umpcr qui représentait des
problématiques donc le premier comité
c'était sur l'éducation et 2e trop vite
et c'était sur les réfugiés
la période du coleader la journée s'est
terminée sur une réunion de gestion de
crise concernant l' attaque de la bande
de gaza le défi véritable j'ai pas
réussi à l'enlever que représentait sa
volonté de convaincre une assemblée
entière d'adopter une certaine position
sur un certain sujet plutôt sujet par
sujet a adopté un ensemble de preuves de
l'ensemble des propositions des
étudiants souvent partie avec un
certificat et deux d'entre eux ont été
élus meilleurs délégué transport à
présent dans ce journal et on va parler
plus précisément de la ligne 18 cette
dernière reliera d'ici à 2030 l'aéroport
d'orly à versailles en passant par saint
quentin en yvelines bonsoir miquel et
demi d'euros de la rédaction de tv 70e
klein 18 c'est déjà une histoire très
longue
une très longue histoire comme vous
l'avez dit la ligne 18 est issu du
projet de réseau de transport public du
grand paris de 2009 pour donner à la
région parisienne une nouvelle impulsion
on l'appelait à ce moment là la ligne
verte le dossier est ensuite repris dans
le projet du grand paris express avec
pour objectif une mise en circulation
envisagé entre 2025 et 2030
le projet avance concrètement le 6 mars
2013 le premier ministre de l'époque
jean marc ayrault dévoile la carte est
le nom de la ligne 18 apparaît pour la
toute première fois dans les documents
le 28 mars 2010 est le tracé devient
d'utilité publique le projet est sur les
rails pour les téléspectateurs est ce qu
on peut rappeler quel sera le tracé de
cette ligne
alors cette ligne de métro automatique
sera longue de 35 km alors reliera donc
à l'horizon 2030 l'aéroport d'orly à
versailles chantiers à terme avec une
première livraison en 2027 entre
saint-aubin et orly dans l'essonne dans
les yvelines la ligne 18 arrivera par
l'est au niveau de châteaufort al
passera ensuite au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour arriver à
la gare de saint quentin est à
guyancourt
ensuite les trains traverseront la ville
pour se diriger vers ça t'aurait à
versailles aline 18 arrivera à
versailles chantiers en passant sous la
nationale 12
il y aura une correspondance avec le rer
si je termine cette chronique par
quelques chiffres la ligne 18 ce sera 10
gars dont trois dans les yvelines à
saint quentin est satory versailles
chantiers sur les 35 km 61 % de la ligne
sera une section souterraine avec le
reste de la ligne en viaduc ou en sous
sol
le coût total ou au sol par dont le coût
total du projet sera lui de 4 5
milliards d'euros d'après le budget à
prévisionnel deux dernières informations
des gorilles léa travaux de génie civil
ont commencé une enquête publique se
déroulera du 28 juin au 28 juillet
concernant le passage au sol d'une
partie à de la ligne merci michael pour
ces précisions et justement va
poursuivre cette discussion à propos de
ce sujet la mise au sol d'une partie du
tronçon avec bertrand guillon bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de magny les
hameaux alors pas de gare dans la
commune elle sera située un peu plus
loin au niveau des communes de
guyancourt et de voisins-le-bretonneux
mais le tracé là in 18 passera bien par
votre commune de magny les hameaux
d'ailleurs on l'a appris en décembre une
partie des 14 km de viaducs sur le
plateau de c à quai sera finalement mise
au sol on parle là d'un tronçon de 5 km
entre le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique de saclay au golf national au
niveau de magny les hameaux
c'est une circulation plus discrète au
niveau visuel et sonore une économie de
30 millions d'euros avance la société du
grand paris qui précise également que
cette décision rend à l'agriculture une
surface de quatre hectares vous
dénonciez de votre côté bertrand guillon
dans les colonnes du parisien une
opération de communication de la société
du grand paris
ce n'est pas quand même un paquet fait
vis-à-vis des des opposants du projet
des opposants sur le projet de viaduc
vous étiez vous même opposé à ce viaduc
il ya deux éléments là dessus il y a le
constat qui est une sclérose de
l'ensemble de notre territoire qui n'est
pas d'aujourd'hui
et face à laquelle rien n'a été fait
depuis des dizaines d'années et
notamment sur les transports qui existe
qui aurait largement pu abattre a depuis
être adaptée ensuite il y a du coup est
ce que cette ligne 18 répond au besoin
par rapport justement être créés à cette
sclérose du territoire et finalement à
cet axe nord sud est qui qui n'est pas
adaptée par rapport à l'évolution de
notre territoire au fil des années et
aujourd'hui on nous propose un axe
structurant qui va sur l'est ouest
alors que les besoins sont sur le nord
sud donc forcément il y a une vraie
interrogation de notre part et au delà
de ça le deuxième constat qu'on peut
faire sur cette ligne c'est que le
projet qui à la base était un projet qui
était totalement sous terrain est devenu
un projet qui est qui est aérien sur la
partie des zones agricoles et en effet
on considère qu'il y à un sacrifice des
espaces agricoles et ruraux pour pouvoir
faire des économies au fil des années
pour un transport structurants qui n'est
peut-être pas forcément le plus utile
dans le secteur on reparlera de 2,7
utilisé puis un groupe d'experts remis
en cause justement cette utilité dans
une lettre ouverte qui a été publié sur
médiapart justement à propos de cette
nouveauté bon qui remonte maintenant à
descendre c'est à dire la mise au sol
d'une partie de ce tronçon en aérien
dont vous parliez est-ce que ça résout
les problèmes est ce que ça en créer
d'autres
à votre avis alors d'abord la société du
grand paris à communiquer sur un fait
qui finalement est encore en étude
aujourd'hui donc il considère comme
acquis quelque chose qui normalement est
encore en discussion mais c'est une
habitude de rouleau compresseur et
ensuite on est mis devant le fait
accompli puisque les décisions en fait
ne sont concernées uniquement cas que
par une chose qui est de réduire au
maximum les coûts sur un projet global
dont justement l'ensemble des éléments
financiers sont envolés au fil des
années alors cette mise au sol
aujourd'hui ne résout pas les
problématiques d'accès et de continuité
agricoles des problématiques de
continuité environnementale des
problématiques de bruit je prends juste
l'exemple du bruit puisque on peut
toujours
nous sortir un certain nombre de
chiffres l'om est ce aujourd'hui
préconise que les bruits dans
l'environnement par rapport au trafic
ferroviaire sera inférieur à 50 4
décibels ou 44 décibels la nuit
le projet qui est au sol ne va pas en
dessous de ses préconisations de l' oms
ce qui fait que dès aujourd'hui nous
avons un transport qui de toute façon
dépasse les préconisations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé par
rapport au bruit dans l'environnement
d'ailleurs l'autorité environnementale
dans un dernier rapport sur justement
ces modifications de la ligne 18 posait
cette problématique de la nuisance
sonore notamment autour de la gare de
saint-quentin est alors d'après un
communiqué de presse de la société du
grand paris qui est paru un peu après le
conseil de surveillance on a appris
qu'une enquête publique qui concernait
justement cette mise au sol d'une partie
de la ligne qui devrait donc se dérouler
du 28 juin au 28 juillet ce que vous en
savez plus sur les tenants et les
aboutissants de cette enquête publique
on n'en sait pas forcément
[Musique]
a priori elle serait serez fixés et avec
le fait qu'il y à des élections et que
du coup on est obligé on serait obligé
de faire cette enquête publique pendant
l'été et donc pendant les congés pendant
la période de vacances scolaires ce que
je regrette
puisque ça va empêcher finalement une
partie de débat d'avoir lieu
et j invite vraiment tous les habitants
à se mobiliser pour pouvoir aller
apporter leur avis par rapport à cette
évolution
décidée par la société du grand paris
elle devrait donc se dérouler entre le
28 juin et le 28 juillet une dernière
chose bertrand ou lyon alors on le sait
cette ligne 18 est un serpent de mer on
en parle depuis plusieurs années avec
aussi des oppositions autour du projet
il ya notamment hills and qui s'est
installé tout récemment sur la partie
essonnienne du tronçon au niveau de
saclay pour contrer ce projet et le 30
avril dernier également à un groupe
d'experts et de citoyens a demandé aux
ministres de revoir le schéma du grand
paris express une lettre ouverte qui est
paru dans média sur mediapart concernant
la ligne 18 ils dénoncent un projet très
coûteux sans grande utilité
avec une fréquentation estimée à ces
basses et il avance en contrepartie des
solutions alternatives
le renforcement du rer b qui ne passe
non loin à gif-sur-yvette à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse notamment du
bus en site propre une liaison également
par câble sont des solutions plus
écologiques moins coûteuse d'après ce
groupe d'experts et de citoyens qu'en
pensez vous en fait d'abord une réaction
par rapport par rapport à la zac qui est
en train de s'installer
ça fait des années qu'on signale alès
gpa l'état et qu'il faut arrêter ces
projets hors sol sans lien avec les
populations locales et à l'encontre
finalement de ce que 10 de ce que
peuvent dire et les alertes que peuvent
faire les élus locaux et forcément à
chaque fois l'état se retrouvera
confronté avec une population qui
n'acceptent plus et la population à
raison par rapport à ça qu'ils
n'acceptent plus ces projets qui sont
lancés par des sachant qu'ils ne
connaissent pas du tout le territoire
sur lequel ils interviennent ensuite ça
fait des années également que nous
signalons qu'il y a des des progrès à
faire et des projets finalement qui sont
en attente depuis des années sur les
transports existants je vais parler par
exemple la prolongation du rer c jusqu à
rambouillet pourquoi pas jusqu'à
chartres même
c'est un projet dont on entend parler
depuis 40 ans je peux vous parler aussi
du rer c entre versailles et massy qui
devrait se transformer en tram train
depuis des années et dont le projet est
sans cesse reculer je peux aussi vous
parler de la rénovation du rer b pour
permettre une multiplication des
fréquences qui est sans cesse repoussée
c'est une et peut-être d'autres projets
avortés et et tous ces projets là
finalement se rajoute également aux
propositions qui sont de nouveau fait
par des experts mais qui sont faites
depuis des années aussi c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un
projet de ligne 18 qui monopolise tous
les débats depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant et qui n'avance pas
d'ailleurs
et qui finalement m'est sous couvert
tout ce qui aurait dû être déjà fait par
l'ensemble des organismes qui en ont la
responsabilité
depuis une quarantaine d'années donc
aujourd'hui presque je demandais ce que
je demande toujours c'est qu'on se
remette tous autour de la table et qu'on
regarde point par point et que chaque
organisme qui a la responsabilité chaque
collectivité l'île de france la région
le département l'état fassent leur
travail pour pouvoir permettre aux
habitants de ce secteur d'avoir des
transports me disent de ce digne de ce
nom et je ne pense pas que la chine 18
règle les problématiques que nous
pouvons avoir sur nos territoires
merci bertrand guillon d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous et je le rappelle vous
êtes le maire de magny les hameaux
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également la commune de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines à une nouvelle
maire joël jega a été élu hier au cours
du conseil municipal elle était jusqu'à
présent la première adjointe de sylvain
guignard démissionnaire dix mois après
son élection l'édile a quitté son poste
suite à des pressions et menaces dont il
a été victime avec sa famille sylvain
guignard a porté plainte à la
gendarmerie une enquête est en cours
la suite à présent de notre dossier de
la rédaction consacrée aux archives
départementales des yvelines qui sont
installés à montigny le bretonneux
on l'a vu hier elles contiennent des
kilomètres -de archives papier photo ou
même des maquettes avec la numérisation
cette mine d'or est aujourd'hui
accessible sur internet et une équipe
s'occupe justement de numériser le
maximum de ressources pour ce deuxième
épisode mais les nippes hockey est allé
à la rencontre justement de cette équipe
il va bientôt être sous le feu des
projecteurs ce sceau de philippe le bel
va être photographiés sur tous les
angles derrière l'objectif jean-bernard
l'un des photographes des archives
départementale des yvelines
les équipes s'occupent en ce moment dans
l'ensemble d'une trentaine de sault ses
cachets officiels apposés sur des actes
pour les authentifier et les fermer pour
garantir le secret fait une photo du
sceau recto verso avec le parchemin qui
lui est propre et ensuite je je fais des
photos du
des détails du sceau de manière à
pouvoir appuyer sur les endroits où ça a
été restauré ou la cire et les
différentes des couleurs sont
différentes
et puis pouvoir me faire des plans un
peu plus cirer sur les écritures de
manière à pouvoir les déchiffrer de
manière un peu plus facile aux archives
ils sont quatre à officier autour de la
numérisation des manipulations délicate
depuis la fin des années 90 pour
sauvegarder des trésors historiques
comme cette carte de chasse datant du
xviiie siècle ou encore ces journaux le
problème de la presse aujourd'hui c'est
que ce sont des supports de papier
relativement ainsi donc ils peuvent
casser au bout de quelques années et
c'est vraiment la priorité aujourd'hui
de pouvoir les sauvegardes et pour les
générations futures
là toutes les archives de presse locale
était conservé dans un dépôt légal au
niveau de la préfecture de chaque
département
malheureusement donc il n'ya pas de
dépôt légal comme aujourd'hui les grands
types de presse nationaux à la
bibliothèque nationale
du coup il ya eu un vrai travail
actuellement de numérisation et de
sauvetage finalement de cette presse qui
est conservée aux archives
départementales mais hélas le dépôt
légal n'étaient pas conservés dans les
meilleures conditions
voir été très lacunaires 7 à 9% défauts
sont aujourd'hui numérisés le prochain
projet ces cinq volumes de l'abrégé de
l'histoire de france
l'histoire des rois de france écrite par
le cardinal de fleury précepteur du
jeune louis 15 un travail de sauvegarde
pour éviter de manipuler trop souvent
ces archives mais aussi un travail de
partage et de transmission
certains de ces documents sont
accessibles aux internautes à travers le
site des archives aujourd'hui pour une
personne qui rentre en sable vous en
avez à peu près 600 qui vont sur le site
internet alors ce qui intéresse le plus
aujourd'hui nos citoyens malgré la très
grande richesse de nos fonds c'est
évidemment les sources généalogiques
c'est à peu près 60% de notre lectorat
qu'on a appelé un moment une gêne et un
autre à côté vous avez aussi des
documents qui sont plutôt liés à
l'histoire foncière notamment le
cadastre avec les matrices cadastrales
qui permet vraiment de faire l'histoire
en fait de sa maison
d'un terrain et si vous aussi vous vous
laissiez tenter en se baladant dans les
fichiers de l'état civil ou peut
notamment découvrir l'acte de naissance
de jacques tatischeff né le 9 octobre
1907 opecst un certain jacques tati et
les archives ou proposent d'ailleurs en
ce moment un sondage pour connaître les
documents que vous souhaiteriez voir
numérisés ce projet se nomme ma série
préférée saison 2 et vous pouvez y
répondre jusqu'au 17 juin prochain à
plaisir le théâtre coluche proposait une
avant première hier mardi viennent 1913
a été présenté devant un public de
professionnels de la culture s'était
présentée par la compagnie influent en
scène qui était en résidence au théâtre
un spectacle qui revient sur l'histoire
d'adolphe hitler lors de son passage à
vienne
justin brasier et mélanie poker viennent
1913 un spectacle présenté par la
compagnie influent en scène mardi 25 mai
au théâtre
coluche à plaisir une pièce qui raconte
les quatre années d'adolphe hitler à
bienne prémices d'un drame antisémite
qui a toute la culture dans la ville
viennoise il y as en émergence en
prémice donc le pire qui va naître c'est
à dire le l'antisémitisme le plus bénin
que j'allais dire
la pièce se joue dans un décor de
kiosque à musique sur scène neuf
comédiens interprètent un total de 23
personnages différents parmi lesquels
adolf hitler
la pièce s'ouvre sur le jour de ses 20
ans le 20 avril 1909 il vient de se
faire refuser à l'académie de vienne
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement il
faut laisser entrevoir le führer qui va
arriver mais il n'est pas encore là il
est encore jeune il est encore idéaliste
d'une certaine manière j'ai travaillé un
personnage qui est assez froid statique
impulsif mais néanmoins très précieux
dans la manière dont qu'il a de
s'exprimer je ne suis pas ton pote ou
pas d'accord c'est quoi mon vote
alors comme ça tu dessines des bâtiments
pas seulement
j'étudie wagner aussi la pièce était en
création au théâtre
coluche de plaisir l'année dernière un
spectacle de sortie de résidents se
présenter aux professionnels
donc c'était important qu'il puisse y
avoir de la presse des journalistes du
bouche à oreille
voilà les comédiens avaient besoin de
jouer devant un public avant de partir
avant avignon parce que c'est comme ça
aussi un spectacle ça se construit avec
les spectateurs
ça fait du bien aussi d'applaudir et
d'avoir eu ce beau spectacle en fait et
ça fait du bien de retrouver du théâtre
vivant avec des vrais acteurs devant
nous c'est vrai que ça traitaient d'un
sujet extrêmement grave
et malgré tout il y avait une certaine
légèreté
une cinquantaine de professionnels du
spectacle étaient présents à l'avant
première
la représentation à destination du
public est programmée et 15 octobre
on se quitte sur ces images l'arrivée à
la mi journée des bleus à clairefontaine
en yvelines l'équipe de france de
football démarre sa préparation pour
l'euro 2020 reportée à cet été en raison
de la crise sanitaire le sélectionneur
didier deschamps a rappelé un groupe de
26 joueurs pour la compétition premier
match le 15 juin face à l'allemagne à
munich d'ici là les coéquipiers d'hugo
lloris prendront part à deux rencontres
amicales le 2 juin contre le pays de
galles à nice et le 8 juin ce sera au
stade de france face à la bulgare et
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
une semaine après la réouverture les
clients sont-ils de retour c'est la
question que posera mélanie poké à ces
invités très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]